We challenged ourselves to create an online
class that would be equal or better in
quality to our Stanford class, but to bring it to anyone in the world for free.
>> We sent out out one email. We are
offering our class to the world free of charge.
>> And within two weeks 50,000 people had signed
up for it. And that grew to 160,000 students from
209 countries.
>> The [INAUDIBLE] is quite amazing. We decided to, to flip the entire
way we teach, rather than lecturing students, we decided to quiz students.
>> A student said this class felt like
sitting in a bar with a really smart friend
whose explaining something you haven't grasped, but are about
to. And, that's exactly what we were aiming for.
>> We're now offering the Historic AI-class
again on the Udacity platform.
>> So, come join us. It's the old technology, still paper and
pencils, but you can take this class for free at your own pace at udacity.com.
[BLANK_AUDIO].